[Musique]
dès le premier jour où je me suis
installé dans le bureau jxstant celui du
président de la République j'ai pensé
que mon devoir serait un jour ou l'autre
de rendre compte aussi intégralement que
possible prévient Jacques Atali en
ouverture de Verbatim le premier volume
de son journal de l'Élysée qui paraît
chez Fillard le résultat 1000 pages
imprimé serré est évidemment passionnant
nous sommes avec lui dans l'intime des
affaires du monde croyez-le on ne se
déprend pas de ce livre dès lors qu'on
l'a entreouvert et l'on se demande
comment tthalie a pu matériellement
consigner aussi précisément le quotidien
du politique mais son talent est tel
qu'il fait de nous des complices et non
pas des voyeurs pourquoi les citoyens
n'excèderaient-ils pas eux aussi au
secret des dieux puisque'après tout ceci
les concerne et cathalie évite toute
allusion à la vie
privée voici entre 1000 exemples Maurice
fort et son poil dans la main désireux
de quitter le gouvernement le fumeux
jgss et son ruineux centre mondial
informatique auquel tout le monde adhère
on se demande pourquoi chesson ministre
gaffeur les problèmes de la télévision
omniprésent stupéfiante prignance de la
mort dans les réflexions et les
références du président et aussi ce
dîner grandiose sans doute auquel
assistait au côté de l'auteur Coluche et
Fernand
brodel
[Musique]